Is there any benefit to hold your coffee at about beyond the 15 minutes if there's benefit to multiple coffee out of us today?
Why not and hold it longer when you trouble?
The answer that would be dull, not really.
Because you'll start to just absorb the coffee and you'll just absorb the coffee in general, but fluid as well as the caffeine.
So you've caught beyond the stimulation and if you're just absorbing the fluid.
So going beyond 15 minutes, no, don't need to.
Is there a benefit to multiple coffee enemies per day? Yes.
And why not hold it longer if you're going to the trouble?
It's because the purpose of the coffee enemies to stimulate the vagal nerve, the parasympathetic radial nerve, 10, the vagus nerve.
So vagal nerve stimulation is the whole purpose behind the coffee enemies, stimulate detox pathways, stimulate flushing the liver, stimulate your bile, motion, stimulate your immune function.
Calm, you, all the benefits of parasympathetic stimulation.
So doing it more often, yes, beneficial.
You have an excursion protocol, if you have people that critically you'll do five a day.
So that's what you want to do.